[Music]
I'm just trying to work this thing out
president gave me a job to do damn it
Glenn what do we tell you no more troops
don't ask for more troops what do you do
you ask for food hanging on deck you
cutting out I can't hear you can you
hear me I can hear you okay something's
wrong here Hey
all right he hears now I can hear you
okay where you saying no no I'll talk to
you later do we need to finish all I
need you're here to clean up the mess
this one is a [ __ ]
right nothing about war is easy bad I
come here to manage this war and I sure
as [ __ ] didn't come here to close it out
come here win
mr. president I you need to behave like
a leader but I am behaving like I did it
I'm unavailable this country won't fight
at night that country won't fight in the
snow we cannot help them and kill them
at the same time it just ain't humanly
possible
you think the Americans call us
[ __ ] all day and this is
considering agriculture a very bad thing
to [ __ ] your own mother all right
in our - ah in our stead you gotta get
me subtraction you need cut through
exactly need to get me some goddamn cut
through
you are miss dinners for Afghanistan and
you've got the gall to kick the only
Afghan in the room off my goddamn table
uh boss I'm pretty sure the Afghan
ambassador here is from Afghanistan
men are imperfect creatures left to
their own devices all they really want
to do is play with their dicks any
chicken man who need to be left let me
come with you yeah okay I'll come with
you way up I'll come with you what did I
do
[Music]